ouais j'ai vu ton dictionnaire de la
pornographie c'est pas le mien même moi
alors je vais te dire même moi j'étais
choqué il ya un article sur le fist
fucking oui on est de traduire cet effet
sa mère ce n'est pas moi qui les
attentions c'est un livre extrêmement
vif que tu préface pour des jeux bref
ans j'ai fait trois antique de dents
dont l'article bunuel qui serait
d'ailleurs extrêmement surpris de se
voir dans un dictionnaire de
pornographie c'est ce que je disais dans
et puis la préface voilà oui et non ça
n'a rien à voir sinon c'est un brave et
élections celui là il y en a
quelques-uns
oui mais c'est une somme je croire si en
plus tu risques en les agressant les
passionnés pas il ya quelques articles
plus intéressant yi gang bang bang bang
vendre des palettes entendu parler je
veux disputer pornographiques sans
parvenir pour nous c'est le ceux qui
écrivent sur les prostituées encore nous
c'est ça devant l'autre et ça c'est
devenu tout à fait autre chose j'ai du
russe qui choque que ce qui offusque que
ce qui est grossier vulgaire ce qu'on ne
parle pas et ne pas parler de ceux de
quoi on ne parle pas est très
intéressant parce qu'il ya énormément de
renseignements il n'y a pas que des
articles sur le marquis de sade
chose c'est bien sociologie redon il n'y
avait pas l'ombre affiche élevé cela
tient aussi à mais voilà ça j'ai appris
en double quoi le fist fucking est aussi
voilà pourriez dans les français ben je
te dire tu vaux jolie le début parce
quils consistant l'intro mission d'une
main entière voire de l'avant bras dans
le rectum coupe acceptation récente dans
le vagin
bon c'est des coulisses de l'exploit le
cru ce sont les coulisses de l'anglais
gong et de l'interjection bang qui imite
le bruit d'une déflagration le mot gang
bang
originalement réservé pour parler d'un
viol collectif désigne aujourd'hui un
acte sexuel volontaire avec un nombre
indéterminé de partenaires et plus
généralement la pratique d'une relation
sexuelle d'une femme avec plusieurs
hommes c'est la phrase suivante que je
trouve intéressante quand il s'agit d'un
homme avec plusieurs femmes
on parle plutôt de rivas gagne bas je
savais tu vois tu veux que je te dise
quelque chose tu l'as lu avec
gourmandise ya sur ma part je suis un
très bon lecteur tu sais que la
championne du monde de bang bang c'est a
eu 7 120 partenaires en même temps non
là après l'autre c'est là dedans c'est
dans ce dictionnaire au passage à l'an
2000 une hardeuse américaine avait fait
le pari de te faire un gang bang avec
2000 aux mains dans la journée
j'en ai dans la journée la nuit disons
rien et n'est pas rien n est pas comme
quoi les le record c'est impossible mais
c'est ouais c'est ça fait combien de
minutes par partie
c'est sur la foi dont celui vous avez
vous avez eu des travaux pratiques ou
pas mais tu fais pas un livre comme ça
c'est une fois tous d'étudier ce 8 août
non je suis quand même tout à fait
effrayer sous la direction de philippe
ii di falco s'est pas d'une folle comme
quoi diffuser le mari de mme enseignants
il fallait que les confesseurs tus
répondre à toutes les questions que leur
poser les fonctionnaires confesser les
pêcheurs qui on a fait à partir de la
fin du xvième siècle des manuels pour
les confesseurs le plus grand auteur et
un jésuite espagnol s'appelait sanchez
qui a passé toute sa vie le malheureux
assis sur des pans de marbre cas ça va
chauffer beaucoup et bien sûr changé
dans les grandes elles changer de banque
c'était très chaud à écrire sur tous les
cas possibles depuis fédéral en parler
après on avait vu présenter des cas et
même il ya eu des canulars en inventer
des choses qu'on allait présenter comme
vrai auquel il répondait il analysé qui
commettait extraordinaire ces énoncés
mal c'était un prêtre il ne pouvait pas
mais il a dû tout prévoir avec des
animaux avec des végétaux avec tout tout
tout ce qui était à oui il y avait à
l'époque on disait qu'il y avait dans
l'île de formose des gens c'était une
légende qui avait une queue au bas de la
colonne vertébrale le petit peu comme
les singes et on lui a raconté que on
avait amené un de ses hommes à queue à
la cour de versailles qu'on l'aurait
placé entre deux femmes et qui s'était
servi de ces deux membres avec les
développer l'une d'elle ayant
tractoriste s'y développer qu'elle avait
pu la pénétrer lui alors on lui a
demandé de trancher de dire qu'est ce
que vous donnez comme pénitence dans ce
cas là
qui est merveilleux cette immensité de
la rue qu'est ce que je faisais c'était
un canular d'étudiants là que deux alors
il a distingué je me rappelle plus assez
mais je crois qu'il a dit que bon dans
un grain cas il y avait sodomie à médéa
la raison dit par des sodomies
incomplète dans ses fins tadic avec la
queue on ne peut pas déjà culte et pas
dans l'autre cas fornication simple mais
comme tu es devenu un spécialiste jean
claude on peut dire aujourd'hui quand il
a été inventé toujours les canons
regarde regarde et encore de quoi un
office fait quitter encore avant les
centres le film fut un temps le fisc n'a
ni en rien de nouveau là dedans puisque
ont procuré sens et qu'on lui a donné un
nom
la taille est de nouveau tombé à raison
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on est
baptisé le fils de qui c'est pas qu'on
les pratiques et j'imagine cette
pratique depuis mais je crois que robben
s'avérait sentir et je crois que l'
usage sexuelle des bébés qui est une des
horreurs
nous avons mis l'art de notre temps et
nouveau j'ai cherché partout je n'ai
rien trouvé
sauf sauf dans une planche des caprices
de goya
moi je crois que c'était celle qui se
fait justement sur scène c'est la
planche 69 exactement des on voit un
homme pratiquer une fellation sur ce qui
a l'air d'être un bébé
on est dans la collision d'un goya 69
des caprices mais c'est tout ce que j'ai
trouvé ni dans les hauteurs orientaux ni
dans pétrole ni danse vénale je n'ai
rien trouvé sur la pédophilie pour ce
stade par exemple commencent à 7 mi
temps mais on voit dans les informations
des faits divers ou des bébé de 15 mois
sont utilisés à des fins sexuelles
aujourd'hui vendu échanger ses démons
alors c'est en sérieuse qui se passe
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de linars
du tube abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu